welcome to this video playing and
Western again I played in the number of
times really I have half a point out of
four games IM remember that i'm always
winning in those games really ever a
point that that's just just fantastic ok
let's consider this disc this was one of
those strange lines night b5 was the
threat well let's see 6 i'm not sure
yeah i know this is a rocky line but
this is just also quite a good line with
93 95 is it see 6086 don't know deform
ok so let's just send the night back
back to be one mmm how do I owe this
maybe still a six was better the night
only five is really a funny piece
yeah yeah this cannot be good really I
need to only need to need to repair this
line this is just just crazy with a
night only five okay how do I do that
actually be six here wow so truly a 6
i'm still I'm still a bit puzzled about
the opening sorry what went wrong down
this looks like the black player has
absolutely no idea about the game Wow
hmm yeah but as though I'm still
optimistic as usual I know that this guy
sometimes playing strange stuff as well
i'm pretty sure that i remember this
correctly
okay yeah he had known I'd be five but
nothing that i really could do about it
and i also don't think it is the end of
the world yep i know but i still a form
quite a good play in the center why does
certainly a bit better you not not sure
how much really bishop maybe bishop a
sex as an idea but i am not sure pusher
b5 might be a move exposing the c6
weakness but something that he needs to
consider carefully i mean i have some
sort of some sort of play on the King
side
yeah he's got all the time I mean this
is really a bit cheeky this move and I'd
be one not defending in any way maybe
it's so ridiculous that you don't need
to do to do any defensive move but I'm
not sure about that okay so Queen g5 my
g4 actually back back it's not bad Nyjah
force the idea now that she has left I
have to pawn okay
so I wonder I wonder if I can do
something like rookie six-week g6 this
is a piece sacrifice but it cannot take
this happen then we tell me you can take
these seven here the lock g6 we are in
one second show yeah I'd love to have
the optimism of those guys sometimes
just I mean I'm thinking of course it
just takes everything ok so let's see
let's see
yeah I assumed it didn't calculate this
because it looks so ridiculous to take
take both stuff and get all the attack
going here but maybe if you can just do
it it's um it's possible check not i'm
not i don't know i don't really know I
see some some dangerous attacking ideas
but i'm not sure if if it's a win for
anything and let's see what now may is
attacking here this is a bit of a
problem Queenie form is a bit of a
problem no matter I thought that this
would be good pretty good actually takes
Queen age three and Queenie for their
still queen age three time morning
now takes g1 mate and takes here oh it
can actually take on f3 with the pond
now night hoist a night something 9393
night have to mate this is the service
working who could work Queen takes Queen
a3 also leads to a mate Queen takes g6
as well you can take on g6 I think
unfortunately you can take on g6 it's
almost working it's always working okay
he didn't she didn't see it so I'm going
to meet him he says why resins yeah
Queen takes 26 was playable yeah I did
yeah still I filled it was totally crazy
that he just took everything instantly
because it is it very dangerous attack
and i still i rather know i feel it's so
totally cool to to just take the seven
like in a second like okay i don't know
let's let's not don't go there okay the
computer says white is totally winning
so it was indeed possible what he did
check okay well this was this was at
least at least them a funny try i came
and it's okay i did Eddie say this is it
is quite cute it is quite cured it's not
working but he put that on the bodice is
a funny line yeah
this is a move that wins pretty pretty
easily in comparison but what you did is
perfectly okay I mean okay I can
theoretically speaking channel for that
but he's got he's got so many pieces
that's just totally winning so I think
what what I did was the relatively best
shot at least it's a bit of a shocker
and I don't it's a bit of a shocker this
move and but he's got Queen g6 and this
is the end of it the the best I can try
us yeah I don't know actually what
probably am PM can chat hick here check
if give this check I just ran out of
material to sacrifice okay and it was
funny I think sorry if I was a bit too
too harsh on him before taking
everything but I just think it's totally
cool to just like in four seconds decide
that ok I'm not going to going to get
made it here because it looks totally it
looks very dangerous I think ok but it
was not working but at the end i was
lucky well thanks for watching